quel bonheur de vous voir alors les
chéris euh je vous le dis euh merci
parce que je reçois plein de SMS bon
courage pourir et
C alors les gars vous êtes hyper gentils
mais sachez-le mais je m'en carre le
plus non mais d'f juste le seul truc que
ça m'apporte euh ce complément d'enquête
j'ai oubl parce qu' y a un complément
d'enquête ce soir sur moi si vous
n'étiez pas courant on dirait que c'est
la finale de la Coupe du Monde euh à
22h50 les chérries le seul truc c'est
que j'ai organisé une soirée de ouf je
pour le regarder ave des potes tout ça
voilà petit traiteur tunisien truc gros
kiff on va regarder après on fait d'ca
petit baby foot truc un kiff bon voilà
mais sinon les gars je vous le dis euh
on sait ce qu'il y a dedans je vous dis
il y a aucune révélation de malade et de
toute façon il y a aucune révélation de
fou sur moi sachez-le voilà après il y a
beaucoup on va pas revenir surt ce
oneviendra demain bien sûr demain on
fera le débrief je sais que vous
l'attendez tous et vous inquiétez pas je
vais me faire un plaisir de faire le
débrief demain je vais me faire une Dar
Mme me si j'ai un petit tournoi de
paddle l'après-midi mais je trouverai
une petite heure pour m'occuper de de de
ce débrief qui sera extrêmement
sympathique voilà donc c'est vrai que
voilà et la bande allnonce a été vu près
de 30 35 ou 40 millions de fois je crois
35 millions de fois c'est incroyable je
crois ce soir à 22h50 moi la seule chose
que j'espère c'est voilà c'est c'est
qu'on soit de soit leader en audience
savez voilà c'est c'est ça c'est ma vie
quoi c'est l'adrénaline quoi voilà c'est
c'est c'est le truc quoi après bien sûr
demain on reviendra sur ce qui est dit
dedans et j'ai vu Tristan Alex ce matin
Tristan balex euh s'ant qui s'embat Alex
ce matin je sais plus on m'a envoyé des
trucs là sur France Info et cetera parce
qu'il a fait le tour du service public
pour faire la promo donc merci à lui
parce que j'espère qu'on va faire un
gros score mais Tristan balex les gars
euh voilà vous allez voir il y a il y a
aussi bon il y a pas de grosses
révélations on va pas vous mentir mais
il y a pas non plus euh voilà il y a
beaucoup de choses aussi qui on n pas
compris quoi on a pas compris d'où ils
les ont sortis et forcément derrière
voilà on va on vous dira ce qu'on en
pense pens ça va être assez marrant
voilà je vous le dis pour le moment je
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on a la
bandeannonce de complément d'enquête on
va voir on va voir la vraie bande
annonce regardez la bandeannonce de
complément d'enquête c'est ce soir moi
je l'adore je ne m'en lasse je vous jure
que c'est vrai je ne m'en lasse pas sur
les 35 millions de fois qu'elle a été
vue j'ai dû la voir 30 millions de fois
et les C autres c'est ma mère elle est
comme une folle elle attend ça elle a
fait une soirée avec des copines et tout
je vous jure que c'est vrai ma mère ce
soir é elle avait deux rêves dans sa vie
que je sois avocat et que je fasse
complément d'enquête et ben
voilà apparemment on prépare un
complément d'enquête sur moi au début il
était ravi puis complément d'enquête a
enquêté et l' inquiété je vous dire la
vérité ce complément d'enquête et je
vous le dis ce soir vous allez voir ils
vont le faire ce sera la fin de
complément d'enquête derrière portrait
de Cyril anona le bouffon devenu roi un
trublillon désormais courtisé par les
milliardaires et qui tu toi les
politiques comment ça va président ça va
très bien coup de pression bidonnage
résotage complément d'enquête sur le
parrain du PAF la plus grosse machine à
buzz de la télé é dur hein complément
d'enquête présenté par Tristan Wallex
c'est jeudi soir juste après Envoyé
Spécial sur France 2 et sur la
plateforme
france.tv 20h24 on est en direct quel
bonheur je vous jure même moi j'attends
ça en direct je te jure c'est un France
Argentine je suis comme un fou ce soir
j'adore j'adore en plus j'adore quand tu
dis du mal de moi donc c'est mon petit
plaisir parce que ici comme vous êtes
tous gentils avec moi à chaque fois e
truc je vais à la boulangerie les gens
oh monsieur Hanouna donc voilà ça fait
plaisir de voir un petit peu des gens
qui me chient dessus et et vraiment ça
me fait un bien fou sachezle mais
vraiment je vous jure vous savez pas
comme je suis excité je suis excité
comme une puce hein vraiment depuis
qu'ils enquêtent sur moi il le sait
alors Medy c'est un de mes meilleurs
amis sachez-le il a été appelé par
complément d'enquête il a il a donc
témoigné dedans c'est un ami d'enfance
il éta avec moi à l'école mais dire 6e
5e 4e 3e ah non il est là mais
quel
cadar au milieu c'est Florent mondolpo
César je c'est vrai FL je sa je me Rapp
très bien t'onacté qui m'as recontacté
Florent monondolfo qui va venir il va
peut-être venir nous faire une surprise
peut-être vous verrez peut-être il a
peut-être une surprise il paraît qu'on
est en train de voir alors mon m dit
déjà déjà comment ça va capillirement
frère pénis sur maamque cette qualité de
cheveux frère c'est c'est quoi ça mais
c'est vraiment il c'était mon voisin
alors donc tu as été contacté par
complément d'enquête oui il voulait quoi
bah Virginie Villard qui a donc réalisé
ce complément d'enquête qui va je pense
faire un un gros carton d'audience
elle m'a contacté en juin juillet ah
mais quand contacte c'est juin juillet
août c'est une tée il faut que tu partes
en vacances un peu Virginie ma chérie et
nous et nous t'inquiètees pas on va on
va on est en train de faire une enquête
sur complément d'enquête je pense que tu
vas être beaucoup appelé aussi tu vas
voir ce que c'est que tu recevoir 42 SMS
par jour quand tu vas voir Jacques
cardos en bas de chez toi tous les
matins pour demander ta réaction je
pense qu'à partir de lundi tu vas passer
un mauvais mois de d donc elle m'a
contacté et elle m'a demandé si
éventuellement je pouvais participer est
sympa très très sympa très professionnel
bien accroché je lui ai demandé
éventuellement de de la rencontrer c'est
ce que nous avons fait pour savoir ce
qu'elle voulait ce qu'elle souhaitait et
résultat des courses j'ai accepté son
invitation et nous sommes partis au Lila
une ville que tu connais bien on a
grandi là-bas grandi au la fil du 93 et
donc on est revenu sur le Cyril des
années collège à C foufou le
CCI et ça s'est très très bien passé
avec Virginie et toute son équipe et
donc tu leur as montré un le je l'urais
montré ton pavillon ouis alors je tiens
à préciser que moi j'avais déménagé ça
c'était la ouais je précise quand même
que j'ai donc participer au complément
d'enquête mais je ne sais pas si je suis
gardé au montage on sait jamaison
apparemment tu es gardé de ce qu'on m'a
dit ah tu l'as vu non je l'ai pas vu
mais j'ai vu un article où il disait il
montre sa maison quoi dans un truc qui
s'appelle je sais plus quoi un truc
voilà mais la photo est folle moi
j'adore sans déconner ah mais
franchement on dirait non mais on dirait
ver bat trip mais sans charer et et là à
côté c'est fl monolfo alors et donc
ouais donc ça s'est bien passé très trs
bienas ditit mais alors je vais dire que
tu as dit beaucoup de choses bien ah bah
oui c'est pour ça seras très donc à mon
avis ce soir je peux te dire que tu
seras très très court dans le en réalité
quand j'ai quand j'ai été contacté par
Virginie la première question qui est
venue c'était potentiellement qui
participit et qui allait potentiellement
dire quoi ou bien évidemment elle peut
pas dire j'ai su en revanche que Valérie
d'ailleurs tu l'as dit très rapidement
qu'elle allait on reviendra sur tout ça
demain parce qu'ils ont dit qu'on a
autorisé personne à parler les gars mais
sa que eux c'est quand même excusez-moi
c'est c'est une Barc ça veut dire eux
ils font un truc pour te défoncer mais
tu vas dire ouais bah appele mon père
appelez ma mère non mais il crois qu'on
va leur donner des gens je vous jure qu'
y avait une Darca un moment ils nous
appelent ils font les gars si vous nous
donnez personne on va pas pouvoir le
faire ce complément d'enquête non mais
ils sont incroyables c'est fou donc toi
toi tu as dit oui j'ai dit oui et bien
évidemment je dit je leur ai dit que on
avait vécu de très très belles années
qu'on avait pris beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses en grandissant au
Lila et elle voulait en gros savoir qui
était le Cyril ouais à cet âge là
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait qu'est-ce qu'il
avait dans la tête comment il vivait sa
sa vie d'enfant et de seras pas beaucoup
ser tu seras pas beaucoup dans le
report te voir ce soir
ici je connais je connais je connais la
télé c'est maouille et compagnie va avir
du montage vousz rien dit de négatif
non est-ce que les questions étaient un
peu orientées parfois pour vous inciter
à
bien évidemment bien évidemment évidment
bien évidemment non elle a demandé elle
a essayé de de savoir ensuite en fait le
le le cheminement ça quand même duré 3h
l'interview je sais pas pour toi 3 He
d'interview 3h d'interview je veux que
vous chronométier ce
soir je parie sur un 15 20 secondes
ouais moi aussi non une minute je pense
une minute je pense tu vas rester une
minute donc en fait on a démarré à côté
à côté de nos maisons ensuite je les ai
amené devant le collège mariecury où
nous étions ensemble ce collège qui a
fait ma légende et après on est allé
dans un dans un parc et c'est au niveau
du du parc où Virginie a essayé quand
même de tenter de savoir comment on
pouvait expliquer que tu étais proche
d'un Vincent boloret d'un Yannick Boloré
et est-ce que à cet âge là on pouvait
éventuellement prédestiner à ce que tu
viennes aujourd'hui deviennes
aujourd'hui le c'est quand même très
pote avec le président du club
d'échèquiv g je dis ça monsieur Assad
ourourian que j'embrasse non mais c'est
doncok tu lui dirais tu réponds quoi
quand on dit ça parce que alors lui
c'est le contraire de moi lui c'est
vraiment un de mes meilleurs potes c'est
vraiment un de mes meilleurs amis c'est
je l'adore je l'aime il le sait c'est
voilà on sa c'est à l'école avec moi il
cartonne c'est un producteur qui fait
des trucs exceptionnels et je suis très
fier de lui d'ailleurs mon Medy d'amour
et c'est vrai que Medy lui il a réponse
à tout c'est parce que lui il est
extrêmement calme moi tu me poses trois
fois la question dis tu commences à me
casser les couilles voilà tu vois lui
c'est genre voilà l'école il était déjà
comme ça tu vois non mais c'est vrai à
l'école déjà Medy c'était tu vois Medy
tu savais que Medy c'était la force
tranquille tu vois non mais je te jure
c'est ta tu savais qu'il y avait pas de
problème avec M il Savit il trouvait
toujours un petit truc trava il sortait
toujours bien à l'école et moi qu'est-ce
que tu lu as dit my qu'est-ce que tu
réponds à ça non il il y a une question
qui était assez je l'avais pas du tout
prémédité celle-ci c'est lorsquelle m'a
posé la question est-ce que c'est pas
compliqué aujourd'hui d'être l'ami de
Cyril Hanouna et donc je l'ai regardé
les yeux dans les yeux et j'ai dit à
Virginie quand on voit ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le monde avec toutes
les difficultés que peuvent vivre plein
plein plein d'êtres humains je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup plus
compliqué que d'être
l'ami il est bon il est vraiment
bon il est bon alors attendez on va
revenir
dessus pourquoi tu as accepté de
participer au départ midi franchement
ouais parce que ça m'embêtait que il y a
trop de témoignag à charge ouais ça
ouais ouais et je lui ai dit les yeux
dans les yeux à Valérie à Virginie parce
que je lui ai demandé de la rencontrer
avant d'accepter c'é important pour moi
d'avoir le contact humain et pour ça
voir un peu ce qu'elle voulait ce
qu'elle souhaitait c'était quoi en gros
le le projet de son complément d'enquête
qui était donc consacré à toi et et en
fait je lui ai je lui ai je lui ai
demandé clairement si déjà dans tous les
témoignages qu'elle avait obtenu c'était
plutôt à charge elle m'a dit clairement
et franchement oui et donc j'ai dit
c'est pas possible je vais pas laisser
mon pote d'enfance dans cette panade
donc c'est c'est mon rôle non mais c'est
mon rle toi qui me connais un peu m oui
dis la vérité parce qu' est-ce que tu me
connais est-ce que tu sais comment je je
voilà j'appréhende ce complément
d'enquête je pense que tu t'en fous
royalement mais je pense
que non est-ce que tu penses que ça me
fait plaisir moi je pense que tu es
heureux moi je pense que tu es content
je pense que ça flatte ton ego ouais
c'est vrai je pense que ça te fait
plaisir il a une forme de consécration
ouais franchement et je vois que tu en
parles quand même sacrément
depuis je veux quand même faire un
record d'audience ouais tu me connais
j'ai fait le record faire record
d'audience de l'Eurovision record
d'audience sur une chaîne de la TNT
j'aimerais faire mon deuxième record
d'audience sur France 2 après
l'Eurovision euh voilà je fais record
d'audience des bêtisiers voilà c'est
c'est c'est un petit peu voilà tu vois
c'est c'est voilà c'est dans le palmars
quoi tu vois c'est comme féérire tu vois
il a gagné ça ça ça voilà non mais voilà
non mais en tout cas de de de ce que
j'entends voilà c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu ce que dit
tout le monde c'est un peu tout ça pour
ça ce soir mais bon on va on va en
parler puisque tu restes avec nous he m
dit Tristan balex euh a fait la promo
partout et nous on a la vraie bande
annonce du complément d'enquête
regardez apparemment on prépare un
complément d'enquête sur moi au début il
était
ravi puis complément d'enquête à enquété
et ne l'a pas de ouf inquiété j'en ai
tellement rien à carer un trublon
courtisé par les plus grands et qui tuoi
les politiques comment ça va président
ça va et vous ma petite couille de tenis
entre ses coups de pression il est venu
il était chaud et tout il a exigé que je
mets de la Rissa dans sa luoubia bon ça
se fait pas mais je l'ai fait il é é
menaçant avec des gros yeux et tout il
m'a fait peur et c'est bidonnage plus
que limite il fait
quoi un chroniqueur actuel à même aosé
témoigner du fait que cyil Hanouna ne le
laisse jamais parler donner son avis et
même
si mais parfois il laisse pas et on
comprend pourquoi nous reviendrons sur
ces différents business qui font sa
fortune estimée à Vlad l'oseille tu veux
une maav et maav
Mad sur la tête d'un canard mais
Madeleine son bon un invité exceptionnel
sur ser aussi présent sur le fauteuil
rouge du moins sur la chaise de jardin
rouge en rapport à l'oseille tout ça
m'appelle béber complément d'enquête sur
le plus gros Parin du PAF c'est ce soir
sur France
2 ça ça va être bien alors on va revenir
sur ce complément d'enquête on va faire
un jeap JAT une séquence qu'on a pas
fait depuis très longtemps vous pouvez
dire est-ce que vous allez zapper est-ce
que vous allez mat et dites-nous
pourquoi alors Tristan balex il a
commencé très tôt il s'est levé aux
Auror 7h40 il était déjà dans la
matinale de France Info il a expliqué
pourquoi il avait enquêté sur moi parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui disent
qu'avc l'argent du service public ils
auraient pu faire autre chose et c'est
vrai que c'est très controversé ce
complément d'enquête en plus c'est il
est beaucoup plus long que ce d'habitude
fait 66 Minutes ouis alors que
d'habitude c'estit 52 ou ouais ouis il
ils ont mis de
l'osaillez pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
absolument voulu enquêter sur lui parce
qu'à complément l'enquête on enquête sur
tous les pouvoirs qui soi médiatiques
politique économique et bah cyil Hanouna
réuni ses ses trois qualités donc voilà
il est plus qu'un animateur on s'est
posé la question quel est l'intérêt
d'enquêter sur lui on estime aujourd'hui
qu'il est reflet il est le reflet d'une
partie de de la société alors non alors
voilà 1 heure plus tard il é allé sur
France 2 dans Télé Matin pour dire que
l'émission serait scénarisée que chaque
chroniqueur serait piloté dans leur
prise de parole euh Tristan tuimagines
si l'émission était scénarisée tu crois
vraiment que que tous les jours vraiment
je prendrai des crises de ner sur Gill
Verdet tu vois pas que j'en peux plus tu
vois pas que je suis au bout de ma vie
avec lui tu vas regarder mon mon Gilou
quand même oui pourquoi tu vas regarder
bah parce que c'est moi j'aime bien les
événements télévisuels çaen a un il y a
un buzz extraordinaire j'ai envie de
voir voilà tout ça pour ça ou alors
est-ce qu'il y aura des trucs voilà moi
je suis en fait qu' a dedans oui mais je
je vais le regarder quand même comme un
téléspectateur qui a envie de voir une
émission de télé et qui la jugera après
mais je suis enthousiaste la soirée est
réservée déjà voilà c'est sûr je suis à
22h50 ah bah oui elle aussi elle a envie
elle dit on va voir etadore elle
amouruse de moi c'est vrai non mais ça
donne envie très franchement de voir ça
voilà c'est il y a un truc électrique
mais vous vous parliez de finale de foot
c'est ça c'est on voit Mbappé non c'est
Anouna voilà je préfère Mbappé quand
même mais c'est clairement un événement
on n' jamais vu autant de promo pour un
complément d'enquête de l'histoire vous
savez l'erreur qu'ils ont fait je vous
jure que c'est vrai et c'est là qu'on
voit que c'est des excusez-moi il voit
un boss comme ça mets-le en prime espèce
de morte que tu es non mais ils vont
faire combien en prime vous allez voir
que c'est vrai pourquoi pour ils l'ont
pas mis en prime ils auraient dû ils
auraient dû switcher moi
ouur
plus sur avec une tu mets pas ise lu en
deè partie la question elle s'est déjà
posée pour d'autres compléments
d'enquête wouh comment il arrive
cel tu mets pas en deè partie de soirée
moi je mets en de partie de soirée il
vaut mieux que tu sois en deè partie de
soirée parce que il y a le foot bien sûr
aprèas raison tu vas ramer r Je suis sûr
que tu B un record ce soir crois ou
franchement et si je mets un record
demain je fais une soirée de demain ici
la fieste à frère laolie tout le monde
prent vas-y mon frère ah ouais la folie
moi je pense vous allez faire record à
l'antenne moi repay et record de Replay
replay ça va être un énorme C même les
gens ils vont aller acheter des jeans
chez Replay je te dis ils vont rien
comprendre V dire je vois le replay il
vont dire donnez-moi de jeans donne-moi
des trucs encore une fois il y a une
promo que ce soit sur les réseaux ou
même à la télé Tristan Val on dirait
qu'il sort un album là il fait tous les
jours on dir qu' en promo son nouv album
c'est une CAD monde mon non mais non
mais on va en parler dans un instant
parce que je vais vous donner d'autres
révélations dans un instant je vais vous
donner des révélations làdessus on va
faire un décryptage de toutes les promos
qu'ils ont fait et il m dit on a
d'autres questions à te poser parce que
je pense qu'on va pas te voir beaucoup
ce soir dans le complément d'enquête et
dans un instant aussi on aura l'avocate
Stéphan faza qui s'exprime pour la
première fois dans tes P et voilà moi je
m'exprimerai un petit peu dans un
instant vous allez voir je vous répondre
à deux trois questions qui sont voilà
qui ont été balayé parce que je vous le
dis c'est pas la c'est pas la folie mais
j'aime bien j'aime bien puis j'ai vu
qu'il y avait Arnaud lagarderre qui
avait témoigné pour moi m'a fait
extrêmement plaisir j'aime beaucoup cet
homme et vraiment ça m'a ça m'a touché
tu vois ça m'a touché a benim aussi
ouais il y a my Benaim et Arnaud la
garder en pour et en a Patrick Sylvie
Tristan
Richard non non mais je sais pas et
sinon ceux qui sont contre ils sont tous
en anonyme ils ont même fait un truc je
vais vous dire dans un instant qu'ils
n'ont jamais fait dans un aucun autre
complément d'enquête je crois c'est une
énorme Darca vous allez voir je vous dis
ça dans un instant et toi tu as des
révélations parce que toi je t'ai vu
depuis ce matin sur Twitter frère toi
frère sans déconner mais tu es déchaîné
toi tu envie d'c toi c'est B c'est BB
avant
[Rires]
avantite